hi Samuel Leeds here and I had a message
a few hours ago from a man called Keegan
and he said that he attended the
property investors crash course some
months ago and he's just completed on a
property that he found at the crash
course today he in Darby so I thought
it'll be a nice idea to drive up and
actually meet him and see what the
property is all about and have a chat
with him because I absolutely love it
when I hear stories of students or the
crash course we've implemented what
they've done on the day stay tuned if
you want to see what happens
[Music]
so this is Keegan and Davi excellent be
good hey I'm I'm really super excited to
be doing this we've been waiting for
this day for a long time and I can't
believe it's finally happening
incredible first property fantastic so
you're the rightful owner of the house
has it built
yeah pretty good did you find the house
I just online through your methods and
came amazing
so we'll go get the keys and then we
level up well Michele wife so that was
the first time that I have seen Keegan
or spoke to him since the crash course
it is literally come on the crash course
and then applied it bought a house it's
a real joy to be with it I'm just
following him up now to the estate
agents to pick up the keys and as soon
as we've got the keys we are gonna look
around this house and hopefully I'm
really hoping that it's a good house I
wouldn't like to have to break it to him
that he's found a bad house
[Music]
congratulations
so Lululemon yeah putting the offer and
they've got the keys at this bust yeah
awesome
that's right thank you ever so much
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you're not going to do like a reaper
then it's just going to be what's your
background but when I viewed the
property actually came with so you've
really adopted the corner of the
teaching you're getting a good power 10
yeah great I'm just soft with people in
what they're doing if you can sort of
form a team to help you that's great
also look at the other reason so
kitchens right and it's got a very
convenient slab garden honest
so here's the okay
and how much will that cost three grand
okay and that includes all the
partitioning and absolutely everything
yeah okay yeah so you'll have two
good-sized ensuite rooms upstairs yeah
and what when we get per room up here so
we're looking at getting five yeah yeah
and the big ensuite room and it's right
in the center of Dharma yeah next moment
you've had that checked out while at
maintenance and they concur with those
prices yeah right what's next so this is
what the basement then yes this is big
private bathroom
that is beautiful yeah from timing you
pay for me to quit for this easy yeah
well one set of council tax suffice or
you can have to pay more than one or all
how does that work so the great thing
about students so no one plays council
tax no so he pays it I've not got any
student accommodation in dari but that
is really appealing so that's gonna save
me big time so I'm looking at
a thousand five hundred yeah the Bulls
including management maintenance
utilities balls obviously yeah all those
things obviously there's no counsel text
you just mentioned that so we can't cash
flow a thousand pounds and what about
the mortgage payments so mortgage
promise you're looking at just over two
hundred pounds a month so standard black
slip so you sang with the bills and the
mortgage that's five hundred very good
and it was yeah just keep making sure
doing the location buying this for 185
even there's a single seven hundred
pounds you know you're gonna get a
really good investment and investment
what's the plans for the future and
what's the net what's the next deal so
I'm looking at some wage
yes actually I mean I'm looking at a
bigger HMO that I joined venturing with
a cash investor so men used to race and
finance their the house next door is
actually owned by the same guy who just
sold this one okay my plan is to do is
try and offer him a nice breathing so
that could be a new bully down there
could be a no money down cry so he
doesn't literally come on the crash
course how much do you pay for the crash
course you could hate to quit
hi guys yeah thanks for coming in and
checking out my first property although
this was my you know if you'd like to
find properties like that yourself
that below market value high cash flow
properties that really would suggest
that you invest in yourself whether
that's with me in the property investors
crash course or elsewhere but just
invest in yourself and take action I
don't know when you're gonna watch this
video but right now I've got a
ridiculous promotional where you can
have two complimentary tickets yes three
tickets to come to the property
investors crash course so depending on
when you're watching this I would just
click the link below and hopefully both
expired and you'll be able to join me
there one earth do I do that
well I do that because I want to make
you easy people to get to know me yes
you'll learn absolutely loads on the
crash course and you'll be able to go
and do it yourself but by giving loads
of value for very little or free in this
case you find what goes around comes
around and I get a lot of clients
I get a lot of satisfaction from it so
take action get yourself booked envoy
training all training elsewhere and I
look forward to working with you and see
you become financially free in the next
year or so god bless
Samuel Leeds here and I'll see you next
time
[Music]